hello freak [ __ ] when I first heard
about the fire thing obviously if I
heard it before my actually my father
going back when I was young he told me
that he was a member of the Flat Earth
Society your father told me there was a
joking around kind of though what he was
doing it in a kind of satirical way
ironically he was doing it because like
he was like saying people are too sure
of themselves and so I'm going to join
the Flat Earth Society he didn't believe
the earth was round so it's been around
for quite a while the Flat Earth Society
at the flat yet the Flat Earth theory
has been around yeah obviously like
thousands of years ago people thought
the earth was round and then slightly a
few a thousand years ago people figured
out that it wasn't here it's figured out
by the ancient Greeks like three
thousand years ago that it wasn't and by
the way it wasn't round it wasn't there
was a flat sorry oh you [ __ ] it up you
gave up the goose you you said thousands
of years ago people thought the earth
was round and they realized it wasn't
yeah you just right now you gave them
fuel that's a quote that's gonna go on
Yahoo [ __ ] I am a shield quote yeah from
the last one yeah that's right that one
a slight misquote yeah so so yeah what
happened was science basically figured
out the shake of the universe and you
know in the 1800's there was like
gentlemen scientists doing all sorts of
kinds of cool things with stars like
measuring the orbits and checking out
how far away things were and discovering
that there were galaxies and things like
that you know that's all the science
going on but then there was this kind of
this guy comes along called Samuel
Rowbotham who published under the name
of parallax in about 1860 and he started
publishing what is basically the same as
Eric de Bey's book that's been published
now pretty much every single thing that
is in Eric de Bey's current book you
will find in Samuel Roberson's book from
1860 and in fact if you read debates
book which I don't recommend you will
see that about 80% of the texts of Eric
today's book is actually quotes from
these books from eighteen hundred's it's
not actually this new stuff that he's
discovered hmm it's all stuff like you
know if somebody walks away from you you
will see that
disappear first and then he has a
two-page quote of Samuel Rowbotham
saying the exact same thing from the
1860s so it's basically recycling this
this theory that started in the 1860s
and then just adding a few little
sprinkles to it liking it saying that
astronauts must be fake and the space
station is fake because in fact
satellites are fake as well yeah Dube
he's hilarious he thinks that dinosaurs
are fake nuclear bombs are fake I mean
there's the idea that one person would
be this mastermind that discovers all
these monumental frauds yeah and Hipple
he yeah I don't think he's claiming to
have discovered these things with lots
of people who think that new clip the
nukes are fake and dinosaurs being fake
is an obvious thing for creationists and
people of that ilk but yea he's
basically recycling theories in a way
that is popular to the reader and
figuring out how to get them across to
people so he right he does these YouTube
videos that are very engaging
yeah and they sound good and then this B
sounds if you don't know what's what did
they sound like they make sense that's
the problem and some of them are quite
technical like at least they use a lot
of technical terms right but they're
they delve into things like there's a
variety of experiments the
michelson-morley experiment that Eddie
mentioned is one of them that keeps
cropping up and then there's which has
never been reproduced that's the
experiment that no Rosalie actually has
been reproduced because it says well the
wrong way not the way that they wanted
the michelson-morley more-- the
michelson-morley experiment was an
experiment to detect the luminiferous
ether which is the supposed medium
through which light travels now back in
the 1800s we didn't know that light was
made up out of photons because light was
was waved so we thought that there was
this stuff that permeated all of space
called the luminous lumen lumen if Aris
ether luminiferous ether it's a little
hard to pronounce and that this is what
light travels through as waves going
through and like didn't know exactly how
it works but the figure there must be
this stuff that permeates all of space
and then they figure that since the
earth was moving and these scientists
actually knew it
the earth was moving so they were using
this as a basis for their experiment
with other if the earth is moving then
they will be able to detect the ether by
doing this experiment so what they did
they set up this experiment with a shot
like one direction and the other
direction then when it came back
together it combined and if they were
moving through the ether or if the ether
was moving through them then the light
that went one way would interfere with
the wrister light that went the other
way so that was the whole experiment was
just just this thing they shot these two
light beams in two directions and they
figured like you know if we turn the
table this way it will change because
we're now going through the ether in
different direction but what happened
was nothing was detected which was kind
of the start of people realizing oh
there is no luminiferous ether right Amy
used that to say that is because the
earth isn't moving that was what the
flatter an airboat ride - yeah they did
they did but Michelson and Morley knew
the earth was moving right they wanted
to figure out whether the ether was
moving with the earth or whether the
earth was moving through the ether right
they were trying to detect the ether so
people who thought that the earth was
the center of the universe not really so
much Bell flattered those people who
were geo centrists people who thought
that the Sun went around the earth and
the whole All Stars went around the
earth there's still people like that
Valley where I am yeah the recent
resurgence some of the thing was Gavin
McInnes sent me something or some guy
thinks that the earth is the center of
the universe essentially he was saying
that it sort of confirms everything in
genesis quiet yeah well I mean if you
need to shoehorn
the whole universe into you know the
descriptions in Genesis then you
probably going to take a few a few
shortcuts so yeah there's these these
experiments like the the
michelson-morley experiment and but
people bring them up and they say that
what they detected was no motion right
but what it actually detected detected
was no luminiferous ether right and
because they detecting no luminaries
luminiferous ether they eventually led
to like theories about what light
actually is which is a wave particle
duality you know the lightest photons
which act both as a wave and as a part
and eventually to the theory of
relativity well you started Medibank
when when did you I think it's about
five years ago but I've been doing the
chemtrail stuff with contrary science
but like over ten years now I just
looking at one of my old posts when the
whole satellite images
I've got surprised at how long I've been
doing it and yeah and Metta bunc been
going about five years and the Flat
Earth stuff came but maybe two years ago
I started to decided to see things about
Flat Earth and a bit over a year ago I
wrote a post on you know what what
should we do about debunking the Flat
Earth and basically they said like all
these people are basically either
trolling or they're crazy so there's no
point addressing either of them and I
think most of them which is trolling
because no one could seriously believe
this it has to be like I don't think
you're right I know I've come to realize
that I'm not I always yeah and that that
post now you know it's gone down the
line but it's it's you know I've almost
dinner like a 180 from that it's
stunning it's really stunning and it's
stunning how many people like this is
why Jamie made these young Jamie calm
you can go and get these flattered chill
shirts that somehow or another we're
being paid to say that the earth is
round like the idea that anybody would
actually believe it I've had so many
people tweet at me I know where your
checks are coming from bro your [ __ ]
sellout I'm a sellout like why would I
you do you don't think that if I really
thought the earth is flat like if
someone thought the earth was flat what
a revelation that would be what an
amazing discovery every scientist would
be clamoring to expose this every single
scientist the idea that all these
scientists who make their name off
discoveries by the way especially a
monumental and provable discovery like
the world being flat like somehow
another they would hide that and then
the big question is why would the
government say the world is flat I mean
why would they in any way why would they
rather hide the fact the world is flat
like what what motivation would anybody
have to show that the world was round
[Applause]
[Music]